for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out moof
university comm thank you and enjoy okay
so we'll start this video series off
with the question of can amino acids be
broken down or oxidized and used for
energy the answer of course is yes is it
something we've mentioned before how
though how is it that amino acids are
oxidized and broke it down for energy
well the first thing that we have to do
is take the amino acids and remove their
alpha amino group and that comes off as
an ammonium ion what we're left with is
the carbon skeleton and that carbon
skeleton has three potential fates the
first fate is complete oxidation in the
TCA cycle to carbon dioxide and water
which is actually what we're going to be
talking about because that's this whole
series is about amino acid oxidation but
that carbon skeleton can also be used in
gluconeogenesis go neo Genesis to give
glucose and a third potential fate is
ketogenesis ketogenesis to give ketone
bodies we're not gonna really talk about
two and three very much we're really
gonna talk about number one because we
want to answer this question of amino
acids being broken down or oxidized and
used for energy so the carbon skeleton
when they went of course when it goes to
the TCA cycle it can give us a bunch of
nadh fadh2 GTP that that carbon skeleton
makes its way somehow or one way or
another to the TCA cycle then those
carbons are oxidized for those reduced
electron equivalents nadh and fadh2 and
of course when you get GTP as well okay
so so this carbon skeleton though we've
talked about it being the alpha keto
acid that amino acid but what is it
really though because not every alpha
keto acid of an amino acid is a TCA
cycle intermediate so what is this
really though well
what we're thinking about is is the idea
that there are six or seven depending on
how you look at it key products of the
carbon skeletons that specifically can
go through the TCA cycle or one of those
other fates which we won't talk about
right now and those six or seven key
products are something that we we really
need to keep that in mind one of them is
alpha ketoglutarate another is sux in
Ocoee third is fumarate fourth
oxaloacetate or oo a 1/5 is pyruvate
sixth acetyl co a ok and the seventh is
acetyl CoA
but I'm not gonna really think about
Osito Osito Kawai too much I'm gonna
take it to basically be just a seed oak
away because I seed oil co co egg it's
just a four carbon
acyl Co way that can be cleaved into two
acetyl co ways so when I think about
carbon skeletons being broken down to
key products the eschewed acetyl co a
just get turned into acetyl co is anyway
so I'm gonna kind of ignore this one
okay so I'm really gonna think about it
being six key products okay and that's
these guys and so we're going to see
these specific reactions or at least
we're gonna get a really good idea of
the specific reactions that actually
take carbon skeletons of amino acids and
give these key products okay alright
speaking of which that's gonna kind of
look like this okay so of course this
has got a lot of details here but this
is just the the TCA cycle for the most
part and all the enzyme citrate synthase
what kind of taste so on and so forth
these are things that you should already
know if you're studying this this
material because a lot of it won't make
sense if you're not really comfortable
with the krebs cycle and the steps that
precede it anyway what's going on here
really that we're paying attention to is
that you'll notice in these light pink
boxes we've got some amino acids there
those are the the glue code gen ik amino
acids and then we've got in this blue or
in this orange box over here we've got
two keto
amino acids and in the blue box we've
got amino acids that are both glucose
genic and ketogenic I'm gonna define
those in the next video but what you can
see here is that these amino acids are
feeding their way by these pink arrows
into one of these boxed intermediates
that we just mentioned right here we got
these guys coming into pyruvate these
guys are going into oxaloacetate these
guys are going in to their feeding their
way in to fumarate these guys two acetyl
or sorry it's a section oka way all
these two alpha ketoglutarate and these
all up here going to acetyl co a so the
point is that what's happening is we're
taking these amino acids and taking
their carbon skeleton and feeding them
into these boxed intermediates pyruvate
XL last eight let's go a I'll get a
little right so I've smoked away and
fumarate and because these these carbon
skeletons can form these amino acids can
feed their way to these intermediates
these intermediates can make their way
through the TCA cycle and we can get
energy out of them okay so that's the
gist of the idea as far as how we can
get energy from amino acids we'd get the
carbon skeleton run it through the TCA
cycle we get some NADH is some GTP some
fadh2s so on and so forth and those are
things that are valued as far as energy
goes okay so uh I hope that video was
helpful see you in the next one thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying